What advice would you give to
someone looking to quit porn?
Well,
I gave some advice a little
earlier about quitting alcohol.
You know,
and I would say it isn't that
you're turning to quit porn.
It's not the right way to think about it.
The right way to think about it is that
you're trying to figure out how to have
a better life.
And so you have to figure out,
well I would say do the future authoring
program and keep your porn addiction in
mind and think so in the first part
of the future authoring program,
it asks you a bunch of questions about
what your life could be like in three to
five years if you took care of yourself
like you were someone that you cared
for.
Um,
and then it asks you questions about
your friends and your family and your
career and your time outside of
work and your health and you know,
the important dimensions of life.
And it,
it asks you to spend
20 minutes writing about how good your
life could be in three to five years if
you got your act together and
did what was good for you.
And then it asked you to write about
the hell you could be in if you didn't.
And so I would say you really need to
do that because porn isn't the issue.
The issue is that you're not living
your life the way you want to.
And so you need a vision of life
that's more compelling than the porn.
And you need a counter
vision to that frightens you.
You know,
because otherwise porn is obviously
extraordinarily gratifying in the short
term,
but,
but you seem to be suffering from the
medium to longterm consequences of its
use.
And so you need a story that you can tell
yourself that's really deeply thought
through about why this is
not appropriate for you.
What's what,
it's how it's hurting you and how it's
minimizing you and perhaps making you
embarrassed and ashamed and more
socially isolated and all of that.
So I would say think about it as
cleaning up your psyche and your behavior
rather than merely start stopping,
stopping poor.
And you also might want to write down,
and you could do this
in a negative vision,
part of the future authoring program.
You got to write down everything bad
that you think porn is doing to you,
because obviously you have some
suspicions that this is not good for you,
right?
That it's,
that it's actually harming
you in some important way.
And so you need to be fully cognizant of
what those ways are and then take them
seriously and decide if that's the
pathway through life on which you wish to
travel and so on.
Then I would also say good luck to you.
You know,
it's,
it's a very good idea to identify one
of your weaknesses and work on it on you
can,
you can strengthen
yourself substantially by,
dude.